I remember cuddling up with Victoria in
that room yeah we were only given water
every couple of days
we ended up eating our own
that you know that was 100 torture
that's probably the closest I've been to
death while living with Eunice
[Music]
I'd never met Eunice Frye
um but my parents I think found her
through religion but the first time I
met her was pretty much the day we moved
out into Eunice's care units arrived in
a bright yellow Volvo it was amazing
um you've never seen a car glow so much
we were very excited to be going on a
road trip we didn't know we were
actually moving house it was myself an
Aloma my elder sister who moved in and
when we got there there were two other
children Charlotte and Victoria
my little brother would come on later on
when he was born
[Music]
we arrived at Eunice's house and it was
it was like a thing of dreams I remember
there was this massive sandpit it was
huge so initially living within this
fight was amazing
um we had a great childhood
but
around 94 things started going really
wrong and very quickly it there was no
build up to it it just went wrong
some chocolate went missing in the house
and
for some reason this just triggered
units to a level we'd never seen before
Victoria and myself andaloma were lined
up in Charlotte's bedroom
and Eunice was just staring at us we're
holding a semi-circle around her so
Eunice got a chair leg and she just beat
down on the tops of our feet as we were
stood in front of her this is the first
time I've ever felt real pain pain now
shakes you it's the first time
I've dropped to the floor in pain but
that wasn't enough Eunice kept going
until someone admitted to stealing the
chocolate this abuse happened started
happening daily she started becoming
obsessed with Japanese torture
techniques and Chinese torture
techniques so we would have to do the
invisible chair so we'd lean up against
the wall and
um in a chair shape and not be allowed
to move and every time we moved a mark
would go on the wall and that would be a
beating later on
so when I was five
um like every other kid in the UK you go
to school
initially this was amazing uh because
there was food and if Eunice didn't
provide it I would take it out of other
kids lunch boxes that started getting
picked up by teachers very quickly one
day I came into school and I had a large
bruise on my arm and I was told to tell
everyone I'd fallen off my bike
so the teachers started asking questions
and within days suddenly we were all
pulled out of school all three of us
and legally home tutored and then we
moved to The Farmhouse
so at this point
there's no one around to save us there
was no power there was no running water
there was no
you know it wasn't really livable
conditions we very rarely actually
stayed in the main house we stayed in a
very leaky mobile home in the garden
if I needed a wash I'd wash under the
hose pipe doesn't matter if it's winter
doesn't matter if it's summer that's how
I washed I had a tiny core of the mobile
home and I shared it with rats I shared
it with ants I shared it with bugs and I
shared it with my Labrador dog
you very quickly become aware that this
isn't normal
after a while
she wasn't getting that you know we
would turn up to beatings and
just a beating it's fine
um we became quite blase about it but
Eunice then changed tactics she would
um she would shock us instead
and she had this big steel old bath in
The Farmhouse and she would fill that
with water she would hold us under the
water until
we blacked out there's nothing more
terrifying than letting out that final
breath of Bubbles and knowing she's not
letting you up
and sometimes she would that's that was
the Mind Game sometimes she would let
you straight up
but just that one or two times she took
it that bit further and you see the
bubbles come up and you know actually I
might die here this is this is bad
there was a big old stove with a metal
plate on it and she randomly just
grabbed Victoria's hand once day and put
it on top like a piece of steak but the
scream Victoria let out I can still hear
that scream
and it was horrific and I used to wake
up quite often hearing that scream and
it's something that will never go away
Victoria was still getting daily
beatings though and this is when she had
the Sandpaper rubbed across her face Etc
but she was still attending church she
was going to the Jehovah's Witnesses and
a few of the Jehovah's Witnesses noticed
and were brave enough to step against
units and say
what's happening and they took her to a
safe place and called the police and
started the ball rolling for
two of the craziest years of my life
they drove me to the hospital
and I met Victoria who I hadn't met in a
year at that point
and she told me you know the game's up
you know they know everything it's time
to come clean
and that's the first time in a long time
that it actually felt safe
foreign
[Music]
she was sentenced to 14 years initially
that was later reduced to 12 and she
served eight and a half years
my my biggest thing out of all this is
she didn't win and it just shows
the strength of the human brain the
strength of the human body that we can
go through all that and make it out the
other side
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the woman who's the cutter came with a
razor and
had done something down there but I
wasn't aware what wasn't really
particularly aware of what she did I
remember the pain so distinctly we
weren't sedated the prayer the pain was
excruciating it was excruciating as you
remember crying I do remember him
screaming